that's right thank you thank you thanks  for pretending you know what this is  okay we've found some of our studio  audience members so interesting so  inspiring we were moved to write songs  about you and write them very quickly  Billy let's find our first subject  [Music]  welcome to the show  welcome to the show handsome peewee home  I love sir that you were really nervous  until you heared handsome and you're  like I'm good I'm good  all right let's let's find out who's  next  [Music]  [Music]  sexy LeBron we love you okay curious  hold on a second excuse me I'm sorry  miss what is your name by the way all  right time for one more let's do it this  plants on their shirts the full of  laughter includes the couple you met at  the Scottsdale  [Music]  that's some orgy  you